[Music]
do you have any kids I do have a 18
month old daughter yes and she's a
mixed-race baby my wife is white I'm
black I was wondering I been like this
the whole time down a little bit German
yeah so yeah my wife is white and you
know I'm trying to end racism one white
wife at the time - so that's we're
trying yes that's your goal my goal so
yeah we have this mixed-race baby which
is kind of a you got to get a mixed-race
baby man all right yeah that's the next
thing that's bigger than the iPad yeah
okay these babies are great I mean the
funny thing is when she was born though
she came out super white looking like
very pale so much so that my wife's
brother was like dude what happened
something's wrong here we got the talk
but babies don't stay the same cause
when they're born I didn't realize that
so now what's funny is that she's
getting darker these day goes by so I'm
having fun charting her color progress I
usually cover of Michael Jackson CD
[Laughter]
[Applause]
she was born she was dangerous yeah then
later she became bad right we're aiming
towards thriller right it's never gonna
be off the wall that's that's too much
to hope for
and Jackson 5 is just a dream this is a
dream there you know we're always
thinking we've made so much progress and
we're past times like this but when you
go out in public with your daughter and
you're and you're holding her do you
ever get awkward glances well it's weird
because the world it's sort of a weird
thing because she's now at this weird
part of her color progress that when I
hold her she looks white but my wife
holds her she looks black so when I go
out the world sees a black guy with a
white baby which is not the most popular
color combination you know we've all
seen the white guy with the black baby
or like a thing happen you got a black
baby to the frame but what happens when
you go out when I go out people see the
black out of the white baby and they get
all like confused and sometimes people I
have fun I go out and people see us
hanging out together and they start to
stare and get weird and so now I have a
little fun game I play where when I see
them staring I look at my daughter look
at those people look back at my daughter
and I take off running
let that book I stole that way baby